of what I understand about the pill and  you guys you too know more than I do  about this but it's like basically it  starves the kid to death right and then  did like where did it happen at the  hospital or were you at home uh no so  this happened at the hospital yeah so  you take one at home and then like you  said I didn't know it would stop the  child right so but yeah you take one at  home then you come I think it's the next  day or in two days and then you have  another pill and it's meant to come out  of you and whatnot well and it is does  it always come out at the hospital if  you do the pills I think some people  have done it at home and it they just it  goes down the toilet you know okay